[Music]
during this holiday season we want to
highlight the importance of food banks
and the food pantries and the millions
of families who depend on them one of
the country's largest food bank says
pantry visits are up look at this number
30 percent since the start of the
pandemic that's a big number about 42
million americans are dealing with food
insecurity in this country
jamie yukas visited a food bank in
minnesota a state where feeding america
says more than 400 000 people are now
facing hunger
curry chicken chow mein
nice once or twice a month bridget and
kevin littlefield visit the open door
pantry food shelf in eagan minnesota the
box of cereal go pretty far
and then i like getting the roast like a
beef roast a pork roast then i can add
potatoes and carrots and onion to it to
make a full meal
bridgette works full time in a
restaurant and kevin is semi-retired
they have two teenage daughters and a
niece at home even though i work
full-time in a full-time job you know
sometimes you need it you know what i
mean just to
get you through to the next payday we
have about eight to ten million pounds
of food in this warehouse million with
an m yes allison o'toole is the ceo of
second harvest heartland one of the
largest food banks in the country
they've distributed more than 200
million pounds of food to central and
southern minnesota since the start of
the pandemic out of here
we can get three things second harvest
heartland supplies open door pantry
where the little fields go when you look
at people like the little fields i think
one of the things that strikes me is
that the mother works for a restaurant
she works in food service and she needs
to be able to still feed her family and
can't that's right are there dozens
hundreds of families like that thousands
of families like that inflation isn't
helping the situation holiday meals will
cost more this year according to the
usda grocery prices were 5.4 percent
higher last october than they were the
year before and the price of meat has
increased double digits o'toole says
it's leaving families strapped and it's
also impacting food banks who source
their own food we're seeing packaging
shortages
freight rates are increased things are
delayed i think there's this idea that
because you're a charity you must be
able to source for free
we don't we've purchased more food than
ever before fill it up as much as you
can when you talk to your partners
across the country what are you hearing
they're facing the same pressures that
we are
the supply chain issues the need is back
up where it was a year ago anything out
of here you want back at the open door
food pantry the little fields are
grateful everybody should be able to
have a warm meal every day you should
never feel
embarrassed or ashamed you know if you
need help come get it you know and then
when you're able to you give back kind
of like what we do because at times
littlefield says we all need that little
extra help you guys take care thank you
stay warm out there for cbs mornings
jamie yukas brooklyn park minnesota
it's true sometimes we all need an extra
hand nice piece jamie